hey everybody welcome back to politics
live from my self-quarantine at my own
place but from my laptop for a change
because I actually recorded this entire
episode while I was traveling actually
in Austria a while back and I decided to
keep this Bank on my computer in case I
didn't have something to upload for a
week which is this week which is also
supposed to be the week that I am well I
was going to be in Paris but I decided
to cancel those trips a few days ago
because of the corona virus which turned
out to be a good decision because at
this point Disney in Paris is closed the
catacombs are closed it's just a bad
idea to go around traveling so instead
I'm back home making videos so that's
kind of also a good thing anyway let's
just get started and not talk about that
for too much because I'm sure you guys
are hearing about it more than enough
already
and let's get to silica slopes which is
the scenario for today now as you might
notice I have a continue button right
here because I actually already started
recording this but let's actually just
act as if I haven't this is a scenario
where you have a small plots of land and
it desolates forested fairly and you
have to use the little space you have at
your disposal to build a charming
amusement park you can buy more land you
can buy more land to expand the park but
you cannot get loans now we need to get
450 guests in the park and have an
overall park rating of 85 percent so the
goals aren't too steep I'll be very
honest and that's a spoiler the girls
aren't too steep but when it comes to
this scenario the main challenge is
really the terrain so for one it is
quite a hilly scenario as you can see
but it's also quite small the amount of
available space is really limited and
you can buy more land so if I start
visualizing that there is a fair bit of
land that you can buy but it's still
going to be the main challenge for this
scenario I would say now this one was
inspired actually by my favorite
scenario in the original roller coaster
tycoon which is called mothball mountain
I believe that's the UK or US version
name and it there is a different name
for it as well but I don't know that
name
I just know that on my RCT it was always
called multiple mountain which is a
really cool scenario with some difficult
terrain and very limited size map and I
always enjoyed that one a lot just
trying to figure out how to puzzle the
pieces the park together in such a way
that it doesn't look overly cramped but
you can still get everything you need
into the small plots of land and yeah
the challenge is pretty much going to be
very similar to that in this scenario
now the rides that we get at the start
are kind of limited as well we do get a
lot of stores so that's nice but we only
have a carousel a ferry or swinging ship
and some very basic coasters to start
off with so with that all said let's
jump into it and see what I made out of
this thing alright so starting off I
need to have a money maker because if I
want this park to actually succeed and
if I want to actually learn from my last
epic failure in Sakura Gardens I really
need to start off with something that
makes sense from a gameplay perspective
now unfortunately as I had to learn the
hard way in the last video you really
can't choose your way out of a situation
like this in this game and shuttle loops
just don't really work which is
unfortunate in a sense but I'm also
really happy about it because it means
that you know you're really forced to
come up with some more realistic ways to
make the park run a profit so in this
case I figured probably the best way to
get started with a steel coaster that
fits into this difficult terrain is not
too expensive but at the same time has
good enough stats to earn some money is
to just build a small launched coaster
now my inspiration here specifically is
from Joker's jinx or any of the premier
and I am launch posters which are
typically referred to as spaghetti ball
coasters now if you look up pictures of
Joker's jinx in Six Flags America
actually I'm just gonna leave a picture
here you can see that it just it's just
a giant bunch of tangled track
it starts out simple enough with a cobra
roll but after that
just evolves into a series of helixes
and corkscrews or intertwined so that's
kind of where the name spaghetti ball
comes from I'm actually not sure how de
facto or official the name spaghetti
ball coaster is I feel like it was not
premiered themselves who coined that
term but the term is just so accepted
within coaster enthusiasts groups that
I'm really not sure if it's like
official or not but that's what we all
call those things and that's what they
look like and that's basically all know
those things I've never actually been on
one myself but I have to say I have been
on Express platform 13 in Wally B
Holland which all things considered is
kind of a spaghetti ball coaster by Vic
OMA although both coasters are actually
like this for a similar reason because
for both coasters there also exists dark
ride versions of Joker's jinks I forgot
what the dark ride version is called but
for express its just rock and roller
coaster in Disney Paris so they're
they're ridiculously compact layouts are
really just a result of the layouts
being designed for indoor use somebody
just decided to put them outside as well
but yeah those things are pretty cool
and a nice way to get a short layouts
with a good bang for our buck if you
will that still delivers some good
excitement ratings so that I can start
charging some ridiculous sums of money
but at the same time doesn't you know
use too much space or too much of my
budget so it's all good gee now this
station is kind of boring I have to
admit that it's only later in this video
then I starts experiment a bit more with
the architecture in this park because
I've had so many Alpine scenarios at
this point that I'm almost starting to
get in that stage where everything is
kind of the same and I start relying on
the same techniques and pieces and color
schemes which is always a bit of a shame
so I'm definitely going to try to
experiment a bit more with the pieces
later on in this video but this station
at first you know just getting into it
it's still a bit more simple it's just a
simple gabled roof going over the
station's rec it
self within 90 degrees rotated from that
a gable sort of toward the entrance kind
of drawing people into the building with
at the the middle section between that's
a nice spire of course because I can't
go without a spire although I do like
the way that the roof of the front of
the station kind of continues down to
this lower level where the entrance of
the queue line is which I think just
also kind of makes sense as a queue line
I'm always trying to pay attention to
the facts that the queue lines in this
game of course won't be realistic in a
sense that real-life queues are much
longer and have lots of switchbacks and
things like this but I do want to follow
some of the realism guidelines and the
King rct3 especially put me on blast on
this on one of the earliest poetics
videos comment sections that Mike Hughes
tended to be quite hidden in the past or
not really have logical layouts or
positions so now I'm really trying to
make sure that they kind of float
through the landscape in a sense that as
a real-life queue line would do even if
on a much smaller scale and that their
entrance is actually very well
recognizable and a clear demarcation of
where you can enter the ride which I
feel like with this coaster it's it's
fairly the case now moving on from this
it's time to get to the entrance area of
the park because I do want to open this
park up and make sure that people can
get to the coaster and yeah hopefully
start earning some money because that's
really my main priority at this point
but there will also be a very small Main
Street section down here and I really
have to emphasize that it's going to be
really small but I thought if I'm going
to put a bunch of buildings anywhere in
this park and have some food courts
toilets and things like that it's not
just realistically at the entrance but
also the entrance is one of the best
spaces to do this I think it makes sense
to have a little alpine village down
here in the valley close to the lake
that's just in real life where you would
find these kinds of villages in the
mountains as well so I think it works
out from cinematic standpoint as well
see that's just what this area is going
to be and then of course
Waterside carousel - because those
things are just always nice and for me
at least this thing along with the chair
swing I - of the flat rides that always
work best when you put them on a
waterfront so yeah here I'm starting
with the entrance area with the the food
market I guess and toilet building at
first and I'm really glad that at least
despite all of the challenges in this
scenario there is a good selection of
stalls because if that wasn't available
I honestly wouldn't know how much more
time it would have taken me to get this
scenario to a decent position but I
think with all this it's much easier to
get started so once again I think the
biggest struggle in this map is trying
to get the buildings to look off grid a
little bit and having those overhanging
roofs that you see in Alpine landscapes
in Europe and actually adding some
detail to the roofs as well I do want to
go a little bit into the Swiss Chalet
style architecture so for this building
I just decided to have the roof stick
over the actual walls by a full tile
which is quite a lot but I think given
the balconies underneath it's the this
sort of walkways that are 1 meter or
well one block above the pathways given
that those are there I think it works
out quite alright so then I also added
some detail to the gables here some
decorations that give it that sort of
Swiss Chalet style vibes and finally
which is something that and I think I've
tried in Park tech before but it's
fairly doable a bunch of stones on the
roof to hold down the roof what you
often find in all kinds of Alpine
landscapes not just in Europe but really
all over the world and this is just a
very old traditional way of creating
roofs is putting lots of big rocks on a
roof to hold down the the wooden pieces
which ever kind of pieces the roof is
made out of so in this case there aren't
any you know really small rocks in
politics so I'm mostly just using bigger
rocks that are sunken into the roof
but I think it creates the same kind of
texture as these these rock covered
roofs that you can find in real life
where the weight of the rocks is used to
keep the roof in place and it's really
interesting how this is one of these
kind of architectural themes that you
find throughout the world I remember a
while ago I was looking into alpine
architecture because Alpine is a strange
term because technically it refers to
the Alps in Europe but then it's also
just generally used to talk about
anything mountainous so there's kind of
a strict and loose definition to the
word there but when it comes to alpine
architecture worldwide it tends to be
very similar it tends to really have
these large overhanging roofs be built
very much out of wood made from
evergreen trees and use techniques such
as these rocks holding down the weight
of the roof so it's really interesting
how you can find very similar looking
buildings all across the world I've seen
some buildings in Nepal for instance
that don't even look too different from
traditional European alpine buildings
and it's cool because in a sense
architecture is always a result of its
natural context and this is even true
for the most modern architecture one of
the interesting sort of local things
about Brutalism whether you're a fan of
Brutalism or not is the fact that many
times especially in older brutalist
buildings the the texture of their
concrete's will really reflect the local
materials as well so even there you can
find some you know local effects the the
the colors of brickwork is always
dependent on whatever kind of clay is in
the country but yeah I'm getting very
very off-topic at this point I decided
to finish the main street with just one
final small building which really just
serves as a seating area for the food
courts because the building with the
stalls in the toilet in it itself didn't
have anything like that
so I decided to just end it separately
like that now moving on here's the
second coaster and it's going to be
quite a bit more interesting than the
first one
it's even going to feature to lift hills
be quite long and a bunch of different
unique elements well it's a girl hour so
you know what do you what do you know
that's usually what they tend to do or
at least if there's any manufacturer
that likes to pour out the the cheesy
tricks and long layouts with different
launches and lift hills it's probably
girl hour I was a fair bit inspired by
takabisha for instance for this ride
although of course given the terrain and
the limitations of the size of the map
it's going to look quite different but
takabisha was kind of my starting point
I wanted to have some kind of Yura
fighter that really felt like it had two
stages to the layouts and I at least
tried to get to that point as much as I
could with this one although actually I
have to say spoiler alerts I did try to
have a little on this thing for a while
but I think I gave up on that idea in
the end I'm actually not sure but yeah
I'm pretty sure but it's still kind of
divided into three sections you'll see
in a minute it's starting off simple
enough with just a Beyond vertical drop
into a loop into an over-banked turn at
this point it is actually still the
standard Eurofighter layout that tends
to be cloned around quite a bit I forgot
which one this is specifically like what
the name was
but it is definitely the start of a
standard Eurofighter layout and then it
also just features a bunch of other
twists and turns and a barrel roll and
then a helix at the end and then that's
the end of the layout it's quite small
it's quite simple but really for a
coaster of that budget I think it
delivers a lot of thrills but yeah for
this one obviously I wanted to do a bit
more so after some meandering around in
this back section of the park we finally
returned to the top of the hill here
where we have a small break run section
that I'm still trying to figure out
exactly at which Heights I want to put
it down it's definitely taking a little
bit of elbow sweat to get it to the
right place and yeah for this at this
point I was also considering having a
lift hill here but
I think in hindsight realistically it's
a little bit unnecessary it doesn't
really need the extra momentum because
it's still quite a ways of above the
station and also a lift Hill like this
just isn't really realistic in real life
you would never see a coaster just go up
and just hook up straight on to a change
just like that you really need a small
break run before the lift hill and I
really didn't have enough space to you
know add a break run and another
separate lift hill so I just ended up
doing it like this now of course the
idea is that I do want to have some path
interaction so later on I'm definitely
going to have some scenery and path work
around that drop and turn it into a
spectacle to see as well for the people
who aren't on the coaster but do you
want to see people go around on it I'm
really still kind of missing the the bnm
dive coaster in this game because this
is technically the vertical coaster in
this game since it is sort of the
vertical drop coaster but then in roller
coaster tycoon of course the vertical
coaster was the B&M dive machine so both
games are kind of correct in their names
but I'm still kind of missing the dive
machine in the vanilla game of course
it's something that you can easily model
to it but it's just something that works
out really well if you need a short
coaster you really want to put on this
play and that just tends to be something
that would work amazing in Scenario mode
I mean for one the vertical drop coaster
in roller coaster tycoon is also one of
the if not the best coaster as far as
money making is concerned because it's
crazy efficient and has a throughput
that's just through the roof and you can
usually get very high excitement ratings
with just very short layouts but yeah
moving on from that game I'm actually
going back to park attacks I decided to
have this hope let's go up here with
some rides and other stuff just to you
know also have some points of interest
to actually visit the top of the hill
for maybe it could be the left
furs of old ruins of some kind of old
castle or whatever but I decided to add
a sort of brick facade made out of the
fences as well as stucco walls and
whichever small pieces I could find to
make small bricks which is the studio kV
technique from the days of old which
just always comes in clutch and finally
also and this was my idea for the entire
time I just wasn't sure if I was going
to be able to put it off without a lift
Hill
but finally I wanted to turn this
section of the drop coaster into a sort
of mineshaft very Baron 1898 esque and
the original idea was indeed to make
this a lift Hill so then it would you
know be a bit more thematic because you
could really come to come to a halt and
then start going up that lift Hill like
the mine Tower as you would see it in
Baron 1898 but I think this is still a
fair compromise it looks pretty cool and
it makes for a cool scene as you drop
into the hole I even built this little
stadium thing where people can walk
around and watch the coaster drop down
into the tunnel so yeah I think that's a
a pretty cool thing to still add
something of interest at the end of the
layouts something that personally I
really like about coasters like
takabisha is the fact that their entire
layout just remains really interesting
because too many coasters of course
suffer from the facts that you lose
energy as you go through the ride like
the the final parts of a roller coaster
layouts are typically the slowest parts
where the forces aren't as intense
anymore and the first drop is very often
the best thing and with a coaster like
takabisha that's just not really the
case because you start out with an
amazing indoor section that actually I'm
not going to spoil for anyone who might
be going to fuji-q highland in the near
future and doesn't know what happens in
doors in takabisha it's just a fun
surprise that I don't want to spoil but
after that you go into a launch section
which is absolutely amazing you have the
first half of the layouts and after that
you climb up the lift hill
you finally do that ridiculous beyond
vertical drop which used to be the
steepest drop in the world still pretty
much is even though it's shared now with
the record of the coaster in the the
Mall of America I think whatever the the
TMT know Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
shellraiser in the some mall in New
Jersey
I always forget the name of the mall
because it's it's such a terrible place
it looks really boring but that poster
is basically takabisha except a one
degree steeper drop which I don't think
anybody's ever going to realize but that
coasters technically took the record
from TECA Bishop I kind of feel like
both coasters sort of share the record
in spirits because it's just the same
exact layouts they just make the drop a
tiny bit steeper to steal the record
that's just vanity records anyway I'm
gonna be super off-topic
I just like that layout because the
signature element is somewhere in the
middle of the layouts and after that you
still have a bunch of really cool
elements and as you slam into the brakes
at the end of the ride you don't have a
single second of downtime or a single
part of the layout that just feels like
you're making your way to the station
and I just love that I think the same
goes for the Fluke phone novgorod's in
Hansa Park which is another girl hour
which honestly really surprised me it is
a coaster with one of the most intense
launches in Europe which is just crazy
it's just this Eurofighter that randomly
has a super intense launch and after
that launch you just do a bunch of cool
elements you come back into building and
then you have another vertical lift so
on vertical drop kind of like psycho
beitia
just on a much smaller scale and with
more theming so these are both just two
really cool rides that in sort of girl
our fashion do a lot with what they're
given and just have these multiple parts
of the layout without really having much
downtime if you will and that's just
what I wanted to do with this coaster
alright sorry that needed this horse
story because I just wanted to gush
about psycho be sure and look for
Novgorod going back to the program
though
I wasn't really too happy with the
mineshafts that I built earlier so this
tower here is a bit more fancy a bit
more mine is looking a bit more proper
and of course this is the vertical drop
at the start of the coaster so in a
sense it is also the weenie of the ride
and the thing that makes the ride as a
whole entity kind of standouts and just
give it some sort of character it's also
connected to the station which I'm
working on right now so all together I
think it'll be a structure that works
quite well but then all of this is just
very ripped off from Baron 1898 it's
just a concept that is way too cool
Baron 1898 is I think one of those
coasters that you could notice within
coaster games like architect and planet
coaster just inspired a lot of people
because still to this day I see many
people you know building something
similar taking inspiration from Baron
1898 and giving it their own spin and
it's just every now and then these
coasters are builds which have this
effect of inspiring a lot of people to
do something similar I think gates
keeper did this very thing in
roller-coaster tycoon 3 I remember a lot
of gate keeper like roller coasters
coming out around the time and Baron
1898 just has this effect on mineshaft
coasters with the lift Hill connected to
the station with a drop straight after
it it's just a really cool scenery
concept and one of the things that
really pulls that coaster together and
makes it so iconic even though the
layout is kind of lame and kind of
forceless let's be honest nobody really
likes the layouts of Baron 1980 1918 98
God how do I keep forgetting the actual
year that the coaster is based on so
finally and this is actually going to be
the the final coaster of this scenario I
wanted to build a floorless coaster I'm
not sure if I really wanted to build a
florida's coaster or if this was just
the coaster that I ended up getting in
research and decided to just stick with
it
but it doesn't really matter I decided
to build a floorless coaster and I
figured that despite the fact that I
already have two pretty intense coasters
that are quite worthy of being signature
coasters for the park I really wanted
that one signature ride which you know
in in the universe could be the
signature coaster of the park and the
main attraction but also it could be my
thumbnail for today because I always
kind of like I'm gonna need a good
thumbnail if I want to appease the the
YouTube algorithmic cons which is such
nonsense because this is just parka text
which has a very unique viewership
anyway so it's not like like Bates
techniques are really going to work too
well but I just like it I just wanted to
build something which would be the the
iconic sort of structure for the park
and I didn't feel like I really had that
with the coaster so far it's also a
really good opportunity to make more use
of the terrain because even though the
Eurofighter and the L AM launch coaster
made some limited use of the terrain I
really felt like I could do a bit more
with it so this floorless coaster is
really hugging it as much as possible
with that station on top of the hill and
the lift hill alongside another hill it
just kind of makes it its way down doing
a bunch of inversions and then it comes
back with very little speed left in the
breakroom so it's a very efficient
coaster that nonetheless I feel doesn't
really mean under too much at the end so
I'm actually quite happy with the
layouts the only struggle was trying to
get these paths to the station building
because that station building is up very
high that's a bit annoying but it was
all part of the plan I have to say
because I just had this idea for a
castle like a station building that I
really wanted to try and it's going to
be and it's going to be a bit annoying
because the coaster track is going above
the station there as well but that's
also just part of the plan
you'll see in a second this was very
much inspired by the station of Left
coaster in lakenya which as you might
know is one of my my favorite coasters
in the world just a
really cool new generation for coma I'm
sure that it's gonna you know be blown
out of the water by the new new
generation for comas that are being
built right now in China and in energy
land area and other places but for now
let coaster is just the best of a coma
I've ever been on and it has a really
cool element which is a corkscrew that's
kind of a corkscrew but a little bit
like just a zero-g roll as well except
it doesn't really hit suraj years
because the corkscrew doesn't really
have that much of a curve to it but yeah
it has a row going through the station
and then the station building is also
just really built around this roll as
well which i think is the really cool
thing sometimes you see stations with
elements going through it but then they
just make the station look like it's
partly broken or there's just a hole in
the building or something but with left
coaster you can clearly see this station
building has been built with the coaster
layout in mind and or vice versa so you
can really see the roof curving around
the elements which is really cool it's
not the most beautiful station ever you
can tell that the materials are quite
cheap but it's just a really cool
concept and the way that it's laid into
the park and the way that the coaster
and the scenery intermingle it's just
it's just really cool sorry I'm gonna
spend like half this episode just
gushing about coasters that I've been on
what else am I gonna do but yeah this
this console kind of tries to do a
similar thing although it will be a bit
different because I couldn't really find
a good way to curve around this this
inversion while making it look decent so
instead I have a bunch of roof
structures on this console and I'm going
to connect them with support beams that
the coaster in version is also connected
to and of course I'm also adding a spire
because every iconic building needs its
one iconic elements so especially for
this sort of Gothic Revival kind of our
architecture castle where you can tell
that it's a castle but it's it's not
really a real car so it's not unreal
of course oh it's more like one of those
18th or 19th century castles that rich
Kings built because they were into
fairytales and I figured they could
build whatever it's that kind of castle
then of course I want to make it a bit
fancy and some detail to it some timber
frames and a fancy spire because that's
just kind of how it goes with these
sorts of buildings something I actually
kind of like in this this final build of
the castle is that break run which
curves around the spire at the bottom
there for some reason it's not really
something I thought about when I created
the layout of the coaster but it just
works out perfectly to kind of frame the
tower and at this lower section to the
castle which helps you know blend the
castle into the rest of this hilly
environment so I'm actually we're really
happy with how that turned out
and as a sort of visual counterweight to
the big spire I'm adding a smaller spire
here one of the cool tricks that I found
out throughout my time of playing Park
text is that despite the fact that we
don't really have any steep spire pieces
aside from the roof piece that I use on
the larger tower there you can
definitely stack a bunch of just normal
shapes on top of each other and by
mixing some cubes and pyramid pieces you
can definitely create some steeper roofs
and they'll always look a tiny bit funky
but it's also a funky in a good way
I think it adds some interesting detail
and it's cooler than my roof where it's
just a single flat texture so yeah one
of the things that just make spire such
a fun thing to build for me are just
that they're amazing opportunities to
mix different pieces in the game
together see how they can work and how
you can use them to create extra levels
of detail it's obviously something that
you can do with walls as well but with
spires you can really just kind of stick
everything into it and see whatever lens
and it's just a really cool way to
experiments and just always come up with
you know a new kind of design of spire
you can always try to evolve and
they never just they just never have to
look the same which is really fun which
also helps because I always need to try
my best to not make my buildings look
the same as buildings of some of my
earlier scenarios that I've played and
actually try to evolve a little bit as a
builder as well so finally for this
section of the park I'm adding a kind of
cave entrance here for the coaster where
I think you can clearly tell that this
is where you need to go if you want to
ride the coaster but it kind of
distances and separates the actual parts
from the castle of the station entrance
which is kind of towering above
everything in this map in general and I
don't really want to look into the guest
view and park text because personally I
like to keep this isometric view intact
because I love the sort of suspense of
disbelief or sort of the filling in the
gaps style of architects so I'm not
going to go into a first-person view but
I can imagine and if you were in a first
person view and you'd be down there and
at valley.the the castle being perched
on top of that hill just creates this
wonderful sense of force perspective
where it looks like a giant castle
especially with that spire brought to
the front whereas in reality the
building isn't really bigger than any of
the other buildings in this map it just
works out that way through to the
natural terrain
now at this point I figured I wasn't you
know putting enough time into detailing
my buildings and I really liked the
trick of creating a roof covered in
stones so I decided to do the same thing
on this building just for the hell of it
it doesn't really change too much about
anything it just it just looks so cool
it's one of these tricks that I kind of
want to use more often but as you might
notice I had to create these horizontal
stripes on the roof by putting a bunch
of cubes together so that's probably the
most annoying part about doing all of
this it takes a lot of efforts to get
those horizontal wooden slats in but
once you do and you can have the stones
sort of resting on those it does create
a really cool interesting looking roof
anyway that's it for this time-lapse
let's jump into the game and see how the
park is doing just like that I managed
to finish the scenario also and I hope
this is not something that you didn't
notice but only now start to notice I
couldn't really filter my voice in the
way that I usually want to because for
some reason whenever I tried to noise
gate in audacity which is what I
normally use to cancel out my breath
noises it just didn't work and it would
mess up the stereo sound so you can hear
me breathing in this whole video and I
find this really weird now that I'm
already editing your earlier sections of
the video but I really hope it's
something you didn't notice before and
actually no I hope it's something you
kind of noticed before and you're not
starting to notice now because then
it'll be extra annoying but anyway no
I'm sorry about that if you did notice
it anyway let's actually move into the
topic of looking at the park my laptop
is being extremely loud in the
background please forgive him this is
this is not really what it's made for so
let's just go on actually I should
probably do the coasters in
chronological order so this one I think
it's the silica twister it actually has
a name which is kind of unusual for my
platters because I normally just like to
play without naming any
but yeah let's just straight skip into
the POV so as you can see oh my god
there's the X button as you can see it's
a pretty simple layout it's not too much
to it it's really kind of just like
chokers jinx except with less helixes
and then of course there's a brake run
hidden inside this building but also
quite relevance is the fact that I could
technically hide a second train here the
only reason that I didn't do it is
because it pretty much is and capacity
still but if the park were busier and if
I couldn't fit as many people on a train
I could also run this thing with two
train ops I think but yeah I mean I
would have to go out of my way to also
add an extra break here but it's
possible anyway moving on from that one
we have the Eurofighter here and I'm
gonna have to see if there's actually a
car in the station that's gonna go
anytime soon yeah I guess yeah there we
go alright so up the lift Hill which is
pretty simple I just used a bunch of
beam pieces to create this vertical
lifts and then you go through the
support structure if you get the two
wheels at the top which is very Baron
1898 esque and drop down into the drop
and this first part is really similar to
standard Eurofighter fare just to turn
around after the loop a bit of an
s-curve but then we start doing
something else going into this dive loop
here and another little airtime Hill
just the pop of airtime tech official
likes to do that as well some twisty
curves into the mid-course brake run
after which we kind of slam into this
holding brake it's not supposed to go
into the holding brake quite that
quickly but it's just kind of something
that ended up happening due to the fact
that cars with people in them go quite a
bit faster than empty cars so the
testing speed doesn't really account for
the actual speed that this coaster rides
through the layout adds something else
that I forgot to note is the fact that I
also used this little brick trick on
some of the other buildings
and for credits to studio kV for coming
up with this idea you can just see a
bunch of castle walls but also small
castle small cubes here or also just
cornice pieces acting as smaller bricks
with a slightly different color just to
give some life into a sort of rocky
brick texture on these walls which is a
really cool trick and I think it
combines well even with the rocky fences
to create a kind of more natural stone
looking texture which is something that
parka tech doesn't really have four
walls but using these kind of pieces I
think you can create the same sort of
atmosphere and then of course we have
this little Main Street area with the
food stalls which are currently running
out of supplies whatever something I
forgot to mention actually though I
actually mentioned it in an earlier
recording of the time-lapse commentary
which I threw away but I actually added
a maypole instead of the fountain which
you could see me build in the time-lapse
because I think this is somatically a
more fitting addition given that this
park would be somewhere in Bavaria or a
tea row or an area like this and hang an
iconic maple would probably just be a
cool addition usually in real life these
things are some sort of pine tree with
only the top still green and then a ring
of some kind of shrubbery I'm not
entirely sure it is but due to the fact
that we don't have round hedges this
video is just kind of what I came up
with so it's a bit of a funky looking
maple but it's something that I feel
still carries the theme of this map and
finally let's take a quick look at the
floralis coaster here where I do think
that the castle is easily the main
weenie and the best part about this map
so this layout actually kind of has a
pre lift section as well which is not
too spectacular but it's always fun to
be able to make use of the terrain to do
things like this and it actually has a
very short lift hill compared
to the total length of the layouts just
because of the fact that this station is
so high and we can use all of the energy
all of the potential energy that we
store here up until it gets to the
station now that row through the station
is kind of slow but I think it also sort
of fits given the fact that it's going
through the station and it interacts
with the scenery in such a way and we
have some other inversions twists and a
little airtime here and then we're back
into the station or more or less the
general area of the station because I
decided to add a mid-course breaker on
here now this is kind of annoying I
guess for the people who are sitting in
the front because well as you can see as
it's stuck on the mid-course or rather
the final brake run it's it's exposed in
the front just because I thought it just
looks better like this I didn't want to
extend the roof to the same length as
the tower so this is what I ended up
doing this is totally form over function
so i'm sure any modernist architect is
gonna hate me for this but whatever I
don't really mind I know that on some
real-life coasters you do have cases
like this as well so for instance I
remember writing helix once and actually
I say once but I've written it a bunch
of times but I've written it in rain
once and I believe it is when you're at
the back and you're at the final brake
run that the entire train is underneath
the roof but you're just outside of it
sometimes it just happens that for
whatever reason the architecture of the
mid-course brake run or if the final
brake run usually doesn't quite match up
to where the trains are going to stand
so it's a bit annoying but I wouldn't
say it's entirely unrealistic
but yeah that is basically it for this
map as you can see it's really very
simple just three coasters a bunch of
flat rides some buildings and that's
just about it so all in all I didn't
actually add that much to this scenario
but I'm really happy with the courses
that I managed to add especially before
this close to the interaction that it
has with the castle I think it's just
really cool it is more of an
omnidirectional building actually that I
made it seemed for a second they're
really trying to make it look cool from
every angle although I have to see well
I have to say well some angles give you
a better view of the sea Ruggiero going
through the station this angle is still
my favorite that's definitely the one
that this is sort of mainly built from
and then I kind of want to show off the
most as well but then when it comes to
an area like the main streets for
instance this building kind of works
very well from the fronts as well
especially when I was building the
Maypole here I was trying to check how
the Main Street area would look from the
front I know it's a bit ridiculous to
call this place a Main Street but given
the limited space in this scenario I
think this is about as Main Street ish
as I think I could get it before I leave
this I'm really gonna have to get an
extra Jennifer because this is it's just
ridiculous I also didn't put a cover
over the carousel for once which is kind
of unusual I guess but I think it works
out like this and for a while I was
considering maybe expanding the park
into this direction but I also have to
say I can't buy any more land and this
is just a really awkward sort of family
where I couldn't really come up with
anything useful to add so I'm leaving it
like this which i think is fair enough
so let's save the park at this point you
might notice that I've already started
on the next scenario
don't pay too much attention to it we'll
keep it a secret which the next one's
going to be and actually I'm very
curious to see what the trophy for this
scenario is going to look like because I
have no idea so it's the little mining
Shack
that makes sense and then the next
scenario I'm not sure if I'm gonna get
anyone yeah okay so we are that looks
like it's Robo Park am i right yeah
there we go
oh that's gonna be fun 600 guests no
loan debts overall point rating etc it's
actually not too difficult of a park but
it's definitely one that lets you very
free to go in a sci-fi theme but next
time it's going to be disaster peaks as
you might have already seen I'm gonna
try and fix up this complete mess of a
park which I'm very curious to see how
that's gonna go because I actually
haven't tested this one much personally
so it might just become it might just
turn into some sort of disaster in terms
of me actually trying to manage it oh
well we'll see hopefully it's gonna be
fine anyway thanks for watching guys and
I hope to see you in the next one